Columbus Short was once the sexy star of
scandal I will apologize every single
day if that'll make things better but in
spring 2014 short and the show parted
ways after his wife at the time got a
restraining order the actor later
admitted to struggles with substance
abuse now he's married again and making
music he sat down with short and his new
wife former video vixen Corrine
Stephan's I mean you know the last year
and a half hasn't been the greatest
headlines do you have any regrets
anything you wish you done differently
um
I wish I would have loved myself sooner
hmm
short and stephon's Matt last spring and
Wed New Year's Day in a low-key ceremony
at home well in you guys's wedding made
it into your music video yeah I mean
that that was the part of my fifth to
save
well tell us a little bit about the
meaning of the song and what works um
you know I hate alarms in the morning
the first verse is like all about what I
hate okay when the cops are behind me
you know all of that but on all the
things I hate most I said he got me
feeling this way and the second verse is
basically everything that I love you
know I love drinking wine in the morning
yeah we're right how I'm excited about
that one it's called unbroken and I'm
broken is basically about this whole
last two years you know what I mean just
I'm still standing and you know I've
been through a lot and I'm here and I'm
happy and I'm whole I have a song called
smile Tom there's basically like when
they are at the mountaintop and they say
you're the laughingstock haha oh but you
know at the end of the day I still smile